cet homme ne cherche pas à vendre deux
sandwiches mais un projet trois minutes
pour convaincre un jury de potentiels
investisseurs c'est le principe de funk
rock lancé par la plateforme de
financement des start up so we found
il y a quatre ans cette compétition
permet de donner un coup de pouce à des
entrepreneurs en recherche de
financement l'objectif c'est de
permettre à des entrepreneurs de pitcher
devant un parterre d'investisseurs
composés de jurys investisseurs fonds
d'investissement réseaux de business
angels mais également membres de
l'écosystème et les grands comptes pour
pouvoir créer un maximum de relation le
funk rock s'est déjà rendu dans cinq
régions dénicher ces finalistes pour
cette édition francilienne 200
entrepreneurs ont envoyé leur
candidature
seuls cinq d'entre eux ont le privilège
de se présenter dans le camion et
argumenter leurs projets face au jury il
y en a pas besoin d'être d'avoir une
fortune énorme pour faire la courte
échelle à des projets fort développement
à fort potentiel un exercice qui ne
s'arrête pas là durant la journée lequel
nous fera deux autres étapes à la
défense puis au ministère des finances
de bercy
au total ce sont une trentaine d'acteurs
de l'écosystème que les candidats vont
pouvoir rencontrer faut trouver comment
dire l'essentiel
et puis puis après il est question c'est
assez pratique de développer lors des
questions réponses
c'est surtout ça qu'on attend nous on
préfère je pense le format un peu
interactifs smart rennes team une agence
immobilière spécialisée dans la sous
location a remporté cette étape
régionale
il gagne son ticket pour la grande
finale le 15 novembre prochain
pas de financement à la clé prévu parfum
de truck mais une visibilité 46 pour le
vainqueur